they've been protesting
all day trying to stop myanmar's
military taking over the power plant
and then this
in the darkness the authorities move in
this is gina in kachin state
some of the hardcore stand firm
hurling what they can find at the
incoming enemy
elsewhere water cannon is visible
as troops sweep the streets
arrest arrest someone says
then the feed cuts
[Music]
two weeks after the coup fear and rumor
are spreading in myanmar
in yangon armoured vehicles had been
seen
for the first time
[Music]
the u.s embassy told residents to seek
shelter during the curfew
with warnings internet and phones could
be cut overnight
meanwhile the protests continue with
demonstrators pleading for outside help
what do we want we need you and protect
the country
in the good way to protect the
demographic also
democracy that all we want
[Applause]
[Music]
ambassadors from canada the eu us and uk
have condemned the ongoing arrests of
activists journalists and politicians
and denounced the use of violence
against demonstrators
but in a week where authorities used
live ammunition
water cannon and increasing force
against their own people
a return to democracy seems like an
increasingly
distant dream siobhan robbins